a very big possibility a very big
possibility that the russians will
invade
[Music]
date 2004
target ukraine
objective election rigging
origins of this order from the highest
levels of the kremlin
since the soviet union broke down and
ukraine became independent in 1991 the
kremlin also known as the russian
governments have been doing everything
in its power to re-establish the great
russian empire georgia armenian
lithuania ukraine and 11 other countries
have made up the soviet union but
ukraine was their number one target with
ukraine on their side russia had a shot
at reclaiming its glory days but after
years of failed negotiations russia
realized that the only way they were
going to make progress was to get a
little dirty
so in 2004 russia's goal was to get a
pro-russian president elected in ukraine
viktor yanukovych instead of the
pro-ukrainian candidate viktor yoshinko
yes both candidates were named victor
to make sure the pro-russian candidate
won russia turned to election rigging
but that wasn't all there was an
assassination attempt on the
pro-ukrainian candidate yoshinko and
then the pro-ukrainian candidate
yoshinko was poisoned with dangerous
amounts of tcdd the most potent dioxin
and a contaminant in agent orange
ukraine's presidency transformed in a
matter of a few weeks this fall
into a gravely ill man his face almost
overnight changed into a scarred bloated
mask doctors found dioxin levels in his
blood six thousand times above normal
although it's not clear if the men
responsible were acting on behalf of
russia one of the men accused of the
poisoning fled to russia and was
immediately granted citizenship
protecting him from extradition and the
election rigging worked pro-russian
candidate viktor yanukovych was
announced the winner unfortunately the
ranking had worked a little too well
it was a little bit too obvious sparking
the orange revolution hundreds of
thousands of pro-democracy ukrainians in
the streets today protested against the
results of the presidential election
when votes were counted again it turned
out that pro-russian yanukovych had
actually lost but that didn't discourage
russia because just six years later they
actually got yanukovych elected for real
and for three sweet years russia had an
obedient ukrainian puppet to boss around
until another uprising in 2013 kicked
yanukovich out again
panics vladimir putin held an all-night
meeting concluding that quotes we must
start working on returning cremia to
russia end quotes
cremia is a peninsula on the black sea
that was a part of ukraine at the time
it's not only an important economic
powerhouse for ukraine but also serves
as the military base to control the
black sea from
so on the 23rd of february pro-russian
protesters held demonstrations in the
crimean city of sivastapol
five days later unmarked russian special
forces troops invaded the streets of
sevastopol occupying the airports and
forcefully took over the parliament of
cremia
a pro-russian government was installed
and within just a few weeks crimea was
declared independent from ukraine
this would be kind of like if america
invaded something like the panama canal
and declared it a separate country from
panama
today eight years after the annexation
of crimea russia and ukraine are again
at another crossroads russia has
deployed over a hundred thousand troops
along its border with ukraine and fears
of a russian invasion are higher than
ever russians have sent saboteurs into
ukraine no progress on the de-escalation
of that massive buildup of 100 000
troops on ukraine's borders judy but the
question is why
[Music]
[Music]
putin has an unimaginable amount of
wealth people like poon have wealth
managers who invest their wealth for
them plebs like us don't have that
pleasure that was until wealthfront came
around wealthfront is an investment
service and app that allows regular
people to start building long-term
wealth by creating a diverse investment
portfolio of low-cost etfs and
wealthfront is super simple to use so
you don't have to be an investment
expert to get started all you need to do
is click the link below sign up answer a
few questions to determine your goals
and deposit as little as hundred dollars
to get started
wealthfront then creates a personalized
portfolio designed to minimize your risk
and maximize your returns in a long-term
way that's way safer than something like
day trading plus the app is super easy
to use here's a quick product demo that
welfare put together so you can see what
their clients are experiencing
wealthfront already manages over 28
billion dollars for more than 450 000
clients it's been voted the best
robo-advisor by both investopedia in
2020 and nerd wallet in 2019. what's
nice about wealthfront is that they're
one of the few companies who actually
disclose their annual returns so if you
go to their website you can see that the
return on a taxable portfolio with a
risk score of eight so more on the
aggressive side currently has a one-year
return of 16.44
but of course past performance isn't
indicative of future performance so if
you're interested in building a diverse
investment portfolio with opportunities
to build long-term wealth all you need
to do is head to invest.wealthfront.com
jake and get started with just 500
plus for up to five thousand dollars you
get free investment management for life
so pause the video and head to
invest.wealthfront.com jake to sign up
today thanks to wealthfront for
sponsoring this video
the history of ukraine is one of
suffering before ukraine was ukraine it
went by a lot of different names and was
ruled by a lot of different people often
at the same time this is going to be
extremely simplified
eventually all these different empires
disappeared and left behind a massive
power vacuum in the region that would
later be known as ukraine while
ukraine's powerful neighbors argued over
who should take control of the region
thousands of russian slaves called serfs
fled from their masters and into crimea
this led to bigger disagreements between
the powers that wanted to control
ukraine and what resulted was the
northern wars
russia took a lot of land during that
war including a huge part of ukraine
this didn't sit well with the people
living in ukraine so they tried to get
their independence quite a few times but
then in 1922 the union of soviet
socialist republics was created and
ukraine officially became part of the
russian empire not only was ukraine
important as an industrial and
agricultural center but it had direct
access to the black sea
from which russia wanted to build a huge
navy to compete with britain and america
then came stalin under his communist
programs ukrainians were forced to farm
and meet crazy production quotas before
getting any of the food themselves
millions of ukrainians starved to death
in what is known as the great famine
as many as 10 million ukrainians starved
to death in 1932 and 1933 thanks to
stalin's agricultural policies which
were not just stupid but also actively
evil i mean there was widespread
starvation in a country that is now the
world's third largest exporter of grain
and when world war ii came along things
only got worse the germans tried to
invade the soviet union killing hundreds
of thousands of ukrainian soldiers and
when the war finally ended things didn't
get much better stalin decided that
ukraine wasn't quite russian enough and
moved a ton of russians into cremia
then following world war ii stalin
forcibly deported the crimean
peninsula's entire indigenous population
of ethnic tatars to central asia so if
you want to point to one individual
who's responsible for a lot of this i
don't want to you know call anyone out
but stalin when stalin eventually died
it was safe to say that the people of
ukraine and russia weren't exactly
friends the new leader of the soviet
union nikita khrushchev tried to change
that but it didn't go as planned and
over the next few decades all ukraine
wanted was to get out from under
russia's thumb and their chance finally
came in 1991
[Music]
[Music]
ukraine had been one of the founding
nations of the soviet union and after
russia it was the most powerful and
populated republic of the soviet union
but ukraine was also done being used as
a pawn for russia's political games so
in 1990 as the soviet union was slowly
losing control of its empire 300
thousand ukrainians participated in a
peaceful demonstration calling for
independence people wanted freedom from
the soviet union but it wasn't going to
be that easy in august 1991 the leaders
of the soviet union tried to remove
their boss mikhail gorbachev and put a
more pro-soviet guy in charge their plan
eventually failed and it was this sort
of meddling and instability that gave
ukraine the final push to declare
independence on december 1st 1991
ukraine held a vote where a whopping 90
of his citizens were in favor of
independence they elected their first
ever president of ukraine and the
country finally had the freedom it was
looking for the only problem was by
declaring independence it had earned
itself a very bitter vengeful neighbor
just imagine if texas the biggest state
in the united states seceded from the
united states it would be the ultimate
slap in the face the ultimate symbol of
a failed nation that its very own state
thought that they would be better off
fending for themselves
so russia wasn't gonna stand by and
watch one of its most important
territories sailed off into the sunsets
if russia was ever going to return to
its glory days it starts with their
former satellite states with ukraine
being the number one targets
[Music]
right off the bat russia got involved in
its newly liberated neighbor's politics
this led to the rigged election of 2004
that we talked about earlier and
although ukraine won that battle it was
far from over because in 2010 that same
pro-russian candidate viktor yanukovych
ran for president again he spent more
than a hundred million dollars on his
campaign and this time he actually won
or at least no one can prove that he
cheated for three glorious years russia
felt like it controlled ukraine again
president yanukovych distanced ukraine
from western europe and nato he listened
to what the kremlin said and things were
pretty great for what was left of the
russian empire until the people got
tired of being led by a russian pawn
again and launched another revolution in
november 2013 massive protests broke out
again after president yanukovych refused
to sign a political and economic deal
with the eu everyone thought the protest
would die down but they only became more
popular by february 2014 they had turned
violence and caused the death of 130
people including 18 police officers
something had to be done
so the ukrainian government decided to
hold early elections to appease the
people president yanukovych bails he
fled the capital before anyone had the
chance to impeach or overthrow him
protesters took control of the
parliaments and voted him out
immediately
russia had just lost his puppet to what
they viewed as a violent and illegal
coup russia immediately invades cremia
afterwards
like we covered earlier crimea is home
to a lot of russians who got moved there
by stalin so when the russian military
invaded they used defending russian
civilians as an excuse the annexation of
crimea started a bloody battle that
killed thousands of people and if you
watch interviews with people living in
crimea today you'll hear mixed feelings
some support the russian control others
oppose it but just because the violence
died down in crimea today doesn't mean
it's not alive and well in other parts
of ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
around the same time russia invaded
cremia russian separatists on the
eastern edge of ukraine also started an
uprising they were trying to take the
territory from ukraine and rejoin russia
war broke out between the ukrainian
soldiers and the separatists and for
almost a year it was a free-for-all but
then a ceasefire in 2015 froze both
sides in their positions what resulted
was strange a mix of modern day combat
were world war one style trench warfare
trenches reduced a high from snipers
drones and artillery why not phones were
used because they can't be bugged or
wiretapped by the russians in some spots
on the border russian and ukrainian
fighters were less than 50 meters away
from each other waiting for the other
side to make a move and over the next
seven years over 14 000 ukrainians will
have been killed during this never
ending battle well i always
proved that it finished already
but
now i can see
where this finish is
because it's a continuous already
already seven years
and
i don't see
where is it at the end
and now it looks like the real war might
just about to begin
if you take
weapon to your
to your
hands
you're the target that's that's all
how would you describe your enemies who
are they are they russians are they
separatists
now
[Music]
in april 2021 russia deploys around 120
000 soldiers to the ukrainian border
panic spread through ukraine and europe
everyone thought this was it russia was
going to invade but then just a few
weeks later all those 120 000 troops
withdrew the kremlin said they were just
participating in a readiness drill and
there was nothing to worry about what
was strange was that even though the
russian troops were drew they left
behind all their heavy weapons and
artillery was this russia's way of
subtly positioning its weapons for
invasion for now the panic subsided but
then 8 months later in december 2021
ukraine sounded the alarm again all
those 120 000 troops had returned more
than 12 of russia's military were
stationed at the very edge of ukraine
and panic set in again it seemed like
poon was making his move ukraine admits
that it wouldn't be able to stop a
full-blown invasion and calls for the
us's help that same month the president
of ukraine claims his intelligence team
has stopped a coup attempt by the
russians the threat of invasion is so
serious that even regular ukrainian
citizens are forming militias to protect
their cities and neighborhoods
my main job i am a lawyer we must be
prepared to defend
if we fail our independence we will
disappear what made you decide to join
the territorial defense forces
my will to defend uh to defend my
country against
oppression russian oppression
and it's not just the men women young
people anyone who can carry a rifle or
seeing it as their duty to prepare for
an invasion
i hope that
this skills i won't use
but i want to be sure that i can and the
worst part is no one knows if russia is
serious
ukraine is the russia what taiwan is to
china a tiny yet strategically important
territory that represents the greatest
insult to your legitimacy it's a beacon
to the people of russia that almost the
same demographic of people can thrive
without being under the thumb of an
authoritarian government whether or not
russia is willing to take ukraine back
with violence and risk world war iii is
yet to be seen but one thing is for sure
after the us didn't retaliate out of a
certain failed withdrawal out of a
certain middle eastern country the odds
of poon taking that chance has
definitely increased
[Music]
you